This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Last week the Supreme Court of the United States upheld a ban on sleeping in public spaces. While the majority in favor of the ruling argued that it was not intended to target the unhoused, it effectively allows cities and states to criminalize homelessness, even when there are no shelters available. We thought now might be a good time to re-air our episode from 2017, which covered the Skid
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。上周，美国最高法院维持了一项禁止在公共场所睡觉的禁令。尽管支持该裁决的多数派辩称，此举并非针对无家可归者，但它实际上允许城市和州将无家可归行为定为犯罪，即使在没有收容所可用的情况下也是如此。我们认为现在是重播我们2017年那一期节目的好时机，那期节目报道了洛杉矶的斯基德罗区。
Row District in Los Angeles. It's about the strategic design decisions undertaken by city planning officials to develop a distinct neighborhood for the homeless. It's hard to overstate the vastness of the Skid Row neighborhood in LA. It spans roughly 50 blocks, which is about one-fifth of the entire downtown area of Los Angeles. In some ways, the streets of Skid Row are a bit like other parts of LA. That's reporter Karla Green.
它讲述了城市规划官员为开发一个独特的无家可归者社区而采取的战略性设计决策。很难夸大洛杉矶斯基德罗社区的广阔程度。它跨越了大约50个街区，约占洛杉矶整个市中心区域的五分之一。在某些方面，斯基德罗的街道和其他洛杉矶地区有点像。那是记者卡拉·格林。
There are corner stores and street vendors selling everything from jewelry to loose cigarettes. There are old brick townhouses filled with low income housing. There are parks where grown-ups gather to talk and children gather to play. But it's also very clear when you've entered Skid Row. For one thing there's the smell. The streets of Skid Row often stink of urine and other excrement, baking under the hot Los Angeles sun. The gutters are lined with trash. And the sidewalks are mostly, and on some blocks entirely, occupied by people's makeshift homes. A dizzying array of tarps and tents stretch out for blocks and blocks,
街角有商店，街头小贩卖着从珠宝到散装香烟的各种东西。有住着低收入人群的老式砖砌联排别墅。有大人们聚在一起聊天、孩子们聚在一起玩耍的公园。但当你进入斯基德罗时，也非常明显。首先是气味。斯基德罗的街道经常散发着尿液和其他排泄物的恶臭，在洛杉矶炎热的阳光下烘烤着。排水沟里堆满了垃圾。人行道上大部分，在某些街区甚至是全部，都被人们的临时住所占据了。令人眼花缭乱的防水布和帐篷绵延了数个街区，
one structure jutting up against the next and the next. And there are lots of people on the street, many of them pushing special red shopping carts. The carts are handed out by a local advocacy group because the police used to arrest people for having what they believed were stolen shopping carts. and they register to give you a shopping cart. And people use it to push their property around and stuff like that.
一个结构紧挨着下一个，再下一个。街上有很多人，其中许多人推着特制的红色购物车。这些购物车是由当地一个倡导组织分发的，因为警察过去常以拥有他们认为是偷来的购物车为由逮捕人们。他们会登记并给你一个购物车。人们用它来推着自己的财产之类的东西。
And the cops hate them. — That's General Dogon walking around Skid Row with me. He's a community organizer and lifelong resident of the neighborhood. He's lived in both low-income housing and on the streets here. — So this year, I was born and raised on Skid Row. My parents met in the 50s.
警察讨厌它们。——那是通用多贡（General Dogon）和我一起在斯基德罗走动。他是一位社区组织者，也是该社区的终身居民。他曾住过这里的低收入住房，也曾流落街头。——所以今年，我在斯基德罗出生长大。我父母是在50年代认识的。
They both got a job at Bullock's Department Store on Seventh and Broadway. They went to lunch, fell in love. I was born nine months later in General Hospital. And I've been downtown ever since. Walking through Skid Row, it's not hard to see when you reach the edge, the line that divides Skid Row from the rest of downtown.
他们都在第七街和百老汇的布洛克百货公司找到了工作。他们去吃午饭，坠入爱河。九个月后，我在总医院出生。从那以后，我就一直待在市中心。走在斯基德罗，不难看出你何时到达了边缘，那条将斯基德罗与市中心其他地方分开的界线。
And if you stand right there, you'll notice that you're at the intersection of two radically different neighborhoods. So Main Street is a divider line. Main Street is the divider line between the haves and the haves not. Because you got homeless people that's sleeping on one side of the street and the loft buildings on the other side of the street. And some of the homeless people lay down in their tent and they can look up and see the TV in the loft building.
如果你站在那里，你会注意到你正处于两个截然不同的社区的交汇处。所以主街（Main Street）是一条分界线。主街是富人和穷人之间的分界线。因为街道的一边睡着无家可归的人，而街道的另一边则是阁楼建筑。一些无家可归的人躺在帐篷里，抬头就能看到阁楼建筑里的电视。
So that's the divider line for your ass. And in Los Angeles, that dividing line between haves and have-nots, between Skid Row and the rest of downtown, it wasn't drawn by accident. It's the result of a very specific plan to keep homeless people on one side and development on the other. It's a plan that, somewhat surprisingly, was written and fought for by advocates of Skid Row's resident population. Back in the early 20th century, the railroad went through downtown Los Angeles, right around where Skid Row is now.
所以这就是你们的分界线。在洛杉矶，那条富人和穷人之间、斯基德罗和市中心其他地方之间的分界线，并非偶然划定。这是一项非常具体的计划的结果，旨在将无家可归者留在这一边，将开发项目留在另一边。令人惊讶的是，这项计划是由斯基德罗居民的倡导者撰写并争取来的。早在20世纪初，铁路就穿过了洛杉矶市中心，就在现在斯基德罗所在的地方附近。
And like many other cities around the country, a neighborhood formed around the train tracks. So, first off, what do we have in front of us here? Well, the first thing. Brian Eck is a Los Angeles city planner. It's a map from 1909. And the reason I bought this out is this pictorial here of 1909 actually predates zoning.
像全国许多其他城市一样，一个社区在铁轨周围形成。那么，首先，我们面前有什么？嗯，第一件事。布莱恩·埃克（Brian Eck）是一位洛杉矶城市规划师。这是一张1909年的地图。我买下这张图的原因是，这张1909年的图画实际上早于分区制。
Back when the area now known as Skid Row started to develop, Eck says there weren't any zoning laws in LA to say what types of developments were allowed in different areas. And so what developed at the time, you kind of have the confluence of the rail and the Los Angeles produce and agricultural markets at the same point, which brought a large transient population
在现在被称为斯基德罗的地区开始发展时，埃克说洛杉矶没有任何分区法来规定不同区域允许进行什么类型的开发。所以当时发展起来的，你有点像是铁路和洛杉矶农产品及农业市场在同一点的汇合，这带来了一个庞大的流动人口，
in terms of the railroad workers and our agricultural workers. I've gone through the archives of the LA Times as mentions of Skid Row back a hundred years ago around the turn of the century. Gary Blasey is a UCLA emeritus professor who was a housing and homeless advocate in and around Skid Row back in the 70s and 80s. So I grew up around the rail yards around downtown and people were referred to in the LA Times as for example bums.
就铁路工人和我们的农业工人而言。我查阅了《洛杉矶时报》的档案，里面有100年前世纪之交时提到斯基德罗的内容。加里·布莱西（Gary Blasey）是一位加州大学洛杉矶分校的荣誉退休教授，他在70年代和80年代曾是斯基德罗及其周边的住房和无家可归者倡导者。所以我是在市中心附近的铁路调车场长大的，当时《洛杉矶时报》里的人被称为，例如，流浪汉。
All the way up into the 70s most people in Skid Row lived in cheap apartments or single-room occupancy hotels or SROs. There were homeless people but fewer than there are now. What I saw when I was a kid was homelessness was just to winos. Again, General Dogon, who was living in Skid Row in the 70s. So you had the occasional winos, and the majority of them was white males,
一直到70年代，斯基德罗的大多数人住在廉价公寓或单人入住酒店（SRO）里。当时有无家可归者，但比现在少。我小时候看到的是，无家可归者只是酒鬼。再次提到通用多贡，他70年代住在斯基德罗。所以你偶尔会看到酒鬼，而且他们大多数是白人男性，
and I remember they used to drink white port and all that kind of stuff. Skid Row was not yet the sprawling, tense city that it would go on to become, but it was still considered a rough neighborhood where people went to seek out drugs or drink all day and sleep on benches. And the homeless population was growing. As Skid Row grew, the greater downtown area of LA was also growing and developing. And
我记得他们过去常喝白波特酒之类的东西。斯基德罗当时还不是后来那种蔓延、紧张的城市，但它仍然被认为是一个粗犷的社区，人们去那里寻找毒品或整天喝酒并睡在长椅上。无家可归者的人数在增加。随着斯基德罗的发展，洛杉矶更大的市中心区域也在增长和发展。而
the developers didn't like what was happening in Skid Row. So, for example, the Union Rescue Mission, it was on Main Street. And there were lots of people there. It was full all the time. There were people lined up outside. A lot of activity there. There was essentially an open-air drug market around the corner of Fifth and Main Street. And so a plan emerged in 1972, a plan drafted by a group of business people and endorsed by many city officials to move Skid Row's population out and develop the area for newer, more moneyed residents.
开发商不喜欢斯基德罗发生的事情。例如，联合救援使团（Union Rescue Mission）就在主街上。那里人很多。它总是满的。外面排着队。那里有很多活动。在第五街和主街的拐角处，基本上有一个露天的毒品市场。因此，1972年出现了一项计划，该计划由一群商人起草，并得到许多城市官员的支持，旨在将斯基德罗的人口迁出，并为更新、更有钱的居民开发该地区。
It was known as the Silver Book Plan, and it was, essentially, to raise Skid Row. Kick everyone out, bulldoze buildings, start fresh. Of course, residents of Skid Row and their advocates didn't like this new plan, and they began thinking about how to fight it. One of those people was Charles L. Sesser, a young lawyer at the time, who remembers coming across some research that showed that when you bulldoze a neighborhood like Skid Row, it just means more Skid Row-like neighborhoods pop up elsewhere. Well, we weren't quite sure whether it was true or not.
它被称为“银书计划”（Silver Book Plan），本质上是要夷平斯基德罗。把每个人赶走，推倒建筑物，重新开始。当然，斯基德罗的居民和他们的倡导者不喜欢这个新计划，他们开始考虑如何反击。其中一个人是查尔斯·L·塞瑟（Charles L. Sesser），当时的一位年轻律师，他记得偶然发现了一些研究，表明当你推倒像斯基德罗这样的社区时，这只是意味着更多类似斯基德罗的社区会在其他地方涌现。嗯，我们不太确定这是不是真的。
Here's L. Sesser admitting that, true or not, the theory was useful. But it was a very useful theory for purposes of saying this is a mistake, that that whole idea was a mistake. The theory that Skid Row would just pop up somewhere else if residents were forced to move scared people who didn't want Skid Row's residents to end up in their neighborhood. Some of these scared people joined the Skid Row activists' cause, and the activists were happy to have them. We really did, you know, come up with this idea that had some scholarly support, but
这是塞瑟承认，无论真假，这个理论很有用。但对于说这是一个错误，整个想法是一个错误来说，这是一个非常有用的理论。如果居民被迫搬迁，斯基德罗就会在其他地方涌现的理论，吓坏了那些不希望斯基德罗居民最终出现在他们社区的人。一些被吓坏的人加入了斯基德罗活动人士的事业，活动人士很高兴有他们加入。我们确实，你知道，提出了这个有一定学术支持的想法，但
also really, really helped the advocacy. And so, armed with their one study, Elsesser and other activists came up with an idea to replace the Silver Book Plan, which, again, would bulldoze Skid Row with another one. Here's Jeff Dietrich, who helped write the new plan. We developed what's called the Blue Book Plan. Jeff Dietrich and his wife, Catherine Morris,
也确实，真的帮助了倡导工作。于是，凭借他们的一项研究，埃尔塞瑟和其他活动人士想出了一个主意来取代“银书计划”（再次强调，该计划会夷平斯基德罗），用另一个计划代替。这是杰夫·迪特里希（Jeff Dietrich），他帮助撰写了新计划。我们制定了所谓的“蓝书计划”（Blue Book Plan）。杰夫·迪特里希和他的妻子凯瑟琳·莫里斯（Catherine Morris），
have been longtime advocates for the homeless. They run a well-known soup kitchen in Skid Row called the Hippie Kitchen. The Blue Book plan was this, to contain the spread of Skid Row. It's basically what's called the containment plan. This new plan, we'll call it the containment plan from here on out, proposed some pretty radical ideas, including getting all the missions and the charities and other homeless services to physically move their offices so they'd be within the newly drawn borders of Skid Row.
一直是无家可归者的长期倡导者。他们在斯基德罗经营着一家著名的救济厨房，叫“嬉皮厨房”（Hippie Kitchen）。“蓝书计划”就是这样，旨在遏制斯基德罗的蔓延。这基本上就是所谓的“遏制计划”。这个新计划——我们从现在起称之为“遏制计划”——提出了一些相当激进的想法，包括让所有的使团、慈善机构和其他无家可归者服务机构在物理上搬迁他们的办公室，这样他们就会在斯基德罗新划定的边界内。
Again, Gary Blasey. The deal was all the services that tend to attract homeless people will be concentrated to the east of Spring Street. And in exchange for that, the redevelopment agency will not only not bulldoze all of the SROs, but it will also fund a separate nonprofit called the SRO Housing. The SRO Housing Trust would be charged
再次提到加里·布莱西。协议是所有倾向于吸引无家可归者的服务都将集中在斯普林街（Spring Street）以东。作为交换，重建局不仅不会推倒所有的SRO，而且还会资助一个名为“SRO住房”（SRO Housing）的独立非营利组织。SRO住房信托基金将负责
with protecting and maintaining a whole slew of low-income housing in Skid Row. The activists spent several months writing and developing the containment plan. And they worked every angle trying to get the city to take it seriously. So someone knew someone in the city council. That's Catherine Morris explaining that they got someone to distribute a draft of the plan to everyone on city council. And so they agreed that while there was a lunch break, that they would bring these in and put them at every place.
保护和维护斯基德罗的一大批低收入住房。活动人士花了几个月的时间撰写和制定“遏制计划”。他们尝试了各种角度，试图让市政府认真对待它。所以有人认识市议会里的某个人。那是凯瑟琳·莫里斯在解释他们如何让人把计划草案分发给市议会的每个人。所以他们同意，在午休时间，他们会把这些带进去，放在每个人的座位上。
So the people came back, the council people came back in, sat down, picked up the first thing on there, start paging through this. Where did this come from? I don't know where it came from. The containment plan was enough of a compromise that somehow, amazingly, it won out. It wasn't know where it came from. The containment plan was enough of a compromise that somehow, amazingly, it won out. It wasn't a legally binding agreement, but it went on to define the
所以人们回来了，议员们回来了，坐下，拿起上面的第一件事，开始翻阅。这是从哪来的？我不知道它是从哪来的。遏制计划是一个足够的妥协，以至于不知何故，令人惊讶地，它胜出了。它不是一份具有法律约束力的协议，但它后来定义了
city's approach to Skid Row for decades. And it was a totally unique approach. Charles Elshuser said no one else was doing what they were doing and nobody really seems to have done it since. Elshuser says he's worked on lots of campaigns to save Skid Row-like neighborhoods or housing projects since the 70s. But Skid Row was the only time he's used containment as a strategy.
城市对斯基德罗几十年的处理方式。这是一种完全独特的方法。查尔斯·埃尔塞瑟说，没有其他人做他们正在做的事情，而且似乎从那以后也没有人真正做过。埃尔塞瑟说，自70年代以来，他参与了许多拯救类似斯基德罗的社区或住房项目的运动。但斯基德罗是他唯一一次使用“遏制”作为策略的地方。
The containment plan made various suggestions on how to keep Skid Row types within the new borders of the neighborhood. There's a section of the plan called Inducements that reads, With public restrooms, benches, and pleasant open spaces within the contained area of Skid Row, the residents might be inclined to confine their activities to the immediate area.
“遏制计划”对如何将斯基德罗类型的人留在社区新边界内提出了各种建议。计划中有一节名为“诱导措施”，写道：“在斯基德罗的遏制区域内，通过公共厕所、长椅和宜人的开放空间，居民可能会倾向于将他们的活动限制在直接区域内。”
That section would serve as a magnet to hold undesirable population elements in Skid Row, not against their will, but of their own accord. And the plan talks about a buffer zone, which would create a border between Skid Row and the rest of downtown. Strong edges will act as buffers between Skid Row and the rest of Central City.
这一节将作为一个磁铁，将不受欢迎的人口元素留在斯基德罗，不是违背他们的意愿，而是出于他们自己的意愿。该计划还谈到了一个缓冲区，它将在斯基德罗和市中心其他地方之间建立一个边界。“强大的边缘将作为斯基德罗和中央城市其他部分之间的缓冲区。”
When the Skid Row resident enters the buffer, the psychological comfort of the familiar Skid Row environment will be lost. He will feel foreign and will not be inclined to travel far from the area of containment. and will not be inclined to travel far from the area of containment. After the containment policy was officially adopted in 1976, the city started to implement it, including many of the meticulous and uncomfortable suggestions of how exactly to contain Skid Row's population, like the buffer zone.
“当斯基德罗居民进入缓冲区时，熟悉的斯基德罗环境带来的心理舒适感就会丧失。他会感到陌生，不会倾向于从遏制区域走得太远。”而且不会倾向于从遏制区域走得太远。在1976年正式通过“遏制政策”后，市政府开始实施它，包括许多关于如何精确遏制斯基德罗人口的细致且令人不舒服的建议，比如缓冲区。
I don't remember how I know this, but I do remember learning it, is that some graduate students from USC were hired basically to shadow people living in Skid Row and to keep track on a map of where they went. And so the question was how broad a buffer zone did you need? How far do people wander from Skid Row? And I think the determination was made that you need a buffer of about two blocks. The city also began using unpleasant design, like annoying bright lights on Skid Row's bordering streets,
我不记得我是怎么知道这个的，但我确实记得学过，就是一些南加州大学的研究生被雇佣，基本上是跟踪住在斯基德罗的人，并在地图上记录他们的去向。所以问题是，你需要多宽的缓冲区？人们从斯基德罗走多远？我想当时的决定是，你需要大约两个街区的缓冲区。市政府还开始使用令人不快的建筑设计，比如在斯基德罗边界街道上安装恼人的明亮灯光，
to keep homeless people from wanting to expand their territory. A Main Street always had the regular fantasy lights, the old metal ones that bent down, and that was it. Again, General Dogon. And so when they start building the lofts on Main Street, they came pacifically and they put these big-ass prison lights. I know they put no prison lights when I see one, all right?
以防止无家可归者想要扩大他们的领地。主街一直有普通的幻想灯，那种弯下来的旧金属灯，就是这样。再次提到通用多贡。所以当他们开始在主街建造阁楼时，他们专门过来，安装了这些巨大的监狱灯。我知道监狱灯是什么样，我一眼就能认出来，好吗？
They're about this big and they're brown. You can go over there and look at them. And that was targeting people who, like me, who come outside the SRO and smoke cigarettes, hang out in front of the building, or just talk. And then there were the more aggressive measures. If you stayed within the borders of Skid Row, Gary Blazey says the cops might not bother you.
它们大约这么大，是棕色的。你可以过去看看它们。那是针对像我这样的人，那些走出SRO抽烟、在建筑物前闲逛或只是聊天的人。然后还有更激进的措施。如果你待在斯基德罗的边界内，加里·布莱西说警察可能不会打扰你。
But... Yeah, if you crossed over that border, then if you looked like you might belong on Skid Row, the cops were going to stop you. The containment zone made some practical sense, both for the city and the residents of Skid Row, but it's also an uncomfortable, dehumanizing idea. It's a warehouse zone. Warehouse is what?
但是……是的，如果你越过了那条边界，那么如果你看起来像是属于斯基德罗的人，警察就会拦住你。遏制区对城市和斯基德罗的居民都有一定的实际意义，但它也是一个令人不舒服、非人化的想法。这是一个仓库区。仓库是什么？
Is where you store shit, right? And so, yeah, the idea was to push all of the city of Los Angeles unfavorable citizens, right, in one general area. Elsesser, the lawyer who helped write the plan, says if the way it's written sounds unempathetic or even offensive, that's because they weren't trying to run a PR campaign. They weren't trying to change politicians minds
是存放垃圾的地方，对吧？所以，是的，这个想法是把洛杉矶市所有不受欢迎的公民，对吧，推到一个总的区域。埃尔塞瑟，那位帮助撰写计划的律师，说如果它的书写方式听起来缺乏同情心甚至令人反感，那是因为他们不是在试图进行公关活动。他们不是在试图改变政客的想法，
about Skid Row's residents. They were desperately trying to change politicians' minds about Skid Row's residents. They were desperately, frantically, trying to save Skid Row from being paved over. And containment was better than doing nothing. Here's Jeff Dietrich again, who co-authored the plan. You know, it's spoken of rather derisively. Maybe we could have thought of a better name. But it's better than, you know... The obliteration plan.
关于斯基德罗居民的想法。他们是在拼命地试图改变政客对斯基德罗居民的想法。他们是在绝望地、疯狂地试图拯救斯基德罗，不让它被铺平。而遏制总比什么都不做要好。这是再次提到杰夫·迪特里希，他是该计划的共同作者。你知道，人们对此说得相当嘲讽。也许我们可以想出一个更好的名字。但它总比，你知道……“抹除计划”要好。
Yeah, right. Exactly. Maybe we could have thought of a better name. But it's better than, you know. The obliteration plan. Yeah, right. Exactly. In case you didn't catch that, he was saying it'd be better than an obliteration plan. For better or worse, over the course of just a few years, LA's skid row became the place to go if you were homeless in Los Angeles.
是的，没错。完全正确。也许我们可以想出一个更好的名字。但它总比，你知道……“抹除计划”要好。是的，没错。完全正确。如果你没听清，他是在说这总比“抹除计划”要好。不管好坏，在短短几年内，洛杉矶的斯基德罗就成了如果你在洛杉矶无家可归，就该去的地方。
Some hospitals would even discharge patients there if they didn't have a fixed address. If you out in South Central, around the BOP, there's very few service providers that give 24-hour access. There's no place out in South Central or community where homeless people can go to and every day get three meals, be able to go take a shower, be able to go use the bathroom, stuff like that. So all the services is concentrated in one area. So out in South Central, if you're homeless, it draws you to Skid Row.
有些医院如果病人没有固定地址，甚至会把他们送到那里。如果你在南中区（South Central），在BOP附近，几乎没有提供24小时服务的服务提供商。在南中区或社区里，没有地方可以让无家可归的人去，每天吃三顿饭，能去洗个澡，能去上厕所之类的。所以所有的服务都集中在一个区域。所以如果你在南中区无家可归，它会把你吸引到斯基德罗。
LA was funneling all of its homeless people to Skid Row. And in the 1980s, the homeless population of Los Angeles began to explode. Crack was decimating black communities across the city, and many of these newly addicted people were going to Skid Row. Today, there's a new epidemic. Smokable cocaine, otherwise known as crack. The super addictive and deadly cocaine concentrate. The crack problem has become a crack crisis, and it's spreading nationwide.
洛杉矶正在把所有的无家可归者引向斯基德罗。在1980年代，洛杉矶的无家可归者人口开始爆炸式增长。快克毒品正在摧毁整个城市的黑人社区，而许多这些新成瘾的人正在前往斯基德罗。今天，有一种新的流行病。可吸食的可卡因，也就是快克。这种超级容易上瘾且致命的可卡因浓缩物。快克问题已经变成了一场快克危机，并且正在全国范围内蔓延。
It is an explosively destructive and often lethal substance which is crushing its users. In the midst of the crack epidemic and the escalating war on drugs, Reagan aggressively cut back the welfare system which drastically shrank the space between poverty and homelessness. Skid Row wasn't mostly white male alcoholics anymore.
这是一种具有爆炸性破坏力且通常致命的物质，正在压垮它的使用者。在快克流行病和不断升级的禁毒战争中，里根政府积极削减了福利制度，这极大地缩小了贫困和无家可归之间的空间。斯基德罗不再主要是白人男性酒鬼了。
For one thing, it became overwhelmingly black. You started seeing families in the streets. People who might have otherwise taken a room in single-occupancy hotels just couldn't afford them anymore. You couldn't live two, three days in a motel in L.A. with $200. So people were like, what the hell?
首先，它变得绝大多数是黑人。你开始在街上看到家庭。那些本来可能在单人入住酒店租个房间的人，再也负担不起了。你在洛杉矶用200美元在汽车旅馆住不了两三天。所以人们就像，搞什么鬼？
I might as well just keep my $200 and get a tent, you know what I mean, and just crash out and save my money to eat on. Gary Blazey was a young advocate at the Legal Aid Foundation at the time, and he remembers that Skid Row was so crowded, it felt unsafe. I went from you would see a few people on a block to you would see a hundred people on a block, meaning that basically people were shoulder to shoulder. And so the density was just, I mean, it was a completely insane place.
我不如留着我的200美元买个帐篷，你知道我的意思吗，然后就凑合着住，省下钱来吃饭。加里·布莱西当时是法律援助基金会的一名年轻倡导者，他记得斯基德罗太拥挤了，感觉不安全。我从一个街区只能看到几个人，变成了在一个街区能看到一百个人，这意味着基本上人们是肩并肩的。所以密度简直是，我的意思是，那是一个完全疯狂的地方。
Blasey remembers that for Christmas of 1984, in an effort to get folks from shelter, he and some other advocates set up two big tents with a bunch of cots on an empty patch of land just opposite City Hall. And pretty soon there were 800 people sleeping on cots in those tents. In the last couple of decades, conditions on Skid Row have changed a bit. There are fewer homeless people. They are no longer sleeping shoulder
布莱西记得1984年的圣诞节，为了让人们住进收容所，他和一些其他倡导者在市政厅对面的一块空地上搭了两个大帐篷，里面放了一堆行军床。很快就有800人睡在那些帐篷里的行军床上。在过去的几十年里，斯基德罗的情况发生了一些变化。无家可归的人少了。他们不再肩并肩地睡在街上。
to shoulder on the street. But Skid Row has endured as a place for homeless people to live and find services, even as other Skid Row-style neighborhoods around the country were eaten up by gentrification and their residents were scattered around their respective cities. And over the years, the sense of community in Skid Row has only gotten stronger. The neighborhoods become not just a hub for social services, but for activism around poverty and homelessness.
但斯基德罗作为无家可归者居住和寻找服务的地方一直存在，即使全国各地其他类似斯基德罗的社区被绅士化吞噬，居民被分散到各自的城市。多年来，斯基德罗的社区意识只增不减。这个社区不仅成为了社会服务的中心，也成为了围绕贫困和无家可归进行激进主义活动的中心。
We've always seen it as community, right? I get more, hey how you doing brother, what's up? Hey how you doing General Dogon? When I walk on this end, Skid Row, than I do when I walk on the Yuppified side. They walk past you like they don't even see you. Something about a lot of them I know, you know, they still don't wave. We don't have no animosity or nothing. This is a community down here.
我们一直把它视为社区，对吧？当我走在斯基德罗这一端时，我得到的“嘿，你好吗兄弟，怎么了？嘿，你好吗通用多贡？”比我走在雅皮士那一端要多得多。他们走过你身边，就像根本没看见你一样。关于他们中的许多人，我知道，你知道，他们仍然不打招呼。我们没有任何敌意之类的。这是一个社区，就在这里。
We work to make this a community. Apart from the containment plan, there's another major reason why Skid Row has not been taken over by new apartment buildings, and that's zoning. Aside from the single room occupancy hotels and a bit of other low income housing that was grandfathered in, most of Skid Row is zoned industrial rather than commercial or residential. Again, city planner Brian Eck. In the eastern half of Skid Row where it is zoned industrial, that has precluded the expansion or the ability to create new housing there.
我们努力使这里成为一个社区。除了“遏制计划”之外，斯基德罗没有被新公寓楼接管的另一个主要原因是分区。除了单人入住酒店和一些其他被祖父条款保护的低收入住房外，斯基德罗的大部分地区被划为工业区，而不是商业或住宅区。再次提到城市规划师布莱恩·埃克。在斯基德罗的东半部，那里被划为工业区，这排除了在那里扩张或创造新住房的能力。
But all of that could soon change. Los Angeles is currently undertaking a total rehaul of its zoning code, starting with downtown. And a lot of Skid Row that was formerly zoned industrial will probably be rezoned as mixed use. There are a lot of vacant buildings in Skid Row, and the city would like to make some of that real estate available for housing. Many residents of Skid Row would love to have new housing.
但这一切很快就会改变。洛杉矶目前正在对其分区法规进行全面彻底的改革，从市中心开始。斯基德罗许多以前被划为工业区的地区很可能会被重新划为混合用途区。斯基德罗有很多空置建筑，市政府希望将其中一些房地产用于住房。斯基德罗的许多居民很乐意拥有新的住房。
They've been asking for it for years. Having more housing has been something that they have expressed as something that's critical for the neighborhood. Having grocery stores with healthy and accessible and cheap food. The city is basically saying, in order to give you housing, we have to rezone.
他们多年来一直要求这样做。拥有更多的住房是他们表达的对社区至关重要的事情。拥有有健康、可获得且便宜食物的杂货店。市政府基本上是在说，为了给你们住房，我们必须重新分区。
But Skid Row residents want new housing in their neighborhood to be affordable. And that isn't something that can be dealt with through zoning. Zoning can say whether an area is industrial or residential or mixed, but it can't say if housing will be affordable. That would have to be done legislatively. Some Skid Row residents believe political leaders
但斯基德罗的居民希望他们社区的新住房是负担得起的。而这并不是可以通过分区来解决的事情。分区可以说明一个区域是工业区、住宅区还是混合区，但它不能说明住房是否负担得起。那必须通过立法来完成。一些斯基德罗居民认为政治领导人
could find a way to build affordable housing in the neighborhood, but instead they'll use the rezoning process as an excuse to open up the real estate market and get them out. Like Craig R. He don't want to give me his last name, but he's a longtime resident of Skid Row. And he says zoning is just a tool. The tool they want to use to get rid of the homeless people and create this new gentrification
可以找到一种在社区内建造经济适用房的方法，但相反，他们会利用重新分区过程作为借口来开放房地产市场并将他们赶走。就像克雷格·R（Craig R.）。他不想告诉我他的姓，但他是一位斯基德罗的长期居民。他说分区只是一个工具。他们想要用来摆脱无家可归者并创造这个新的绅士化项目的工具
program is zoning. They're planning on making billions of dollars by pushing us out, squeezing us out or kicking us out, meaning us the poor people, the disadvantaged people, the homeless and plus the residents of the neighborhood. Even without zoning changes, Skid Row is getting smaller. Containment was never a legally binding agreement, and the city seems to be increasingly less guided by it. There's a whole neighborhood actually that juts up against Skid Row that used to essentially be a part of it. It's a new hip neighborhood filled with art galleries and
就是分区。他们计划通过把我们推出去、挤出去或踢出去来赚取数十亿美元，这意味着我们这些穷人、弱势群体、无家可归者以及社区的居民。即使没有分区变化，斯基德罗也在变小。“遏制”从来不是一份具有法律约束力的协议，而且市政府似乎越来越少地受到它的指导。实际上，有一个完整的社区紧挨着斯基德罗，它曾经基本上是它的一部分。这是一个新的时髦社区，到处都是艺术画廊和
chic cafes. It's called the Arts District. And as the areas around Skid Row have continued to gentrify, taking bites out of the edges of the neighborhood, Skid Row itself has changed. Including, General Dogon says, the police presence. In 2006, the city launched what they call the Safer Cities Initiative, which brought 110 extra police to Skid Row. So that containment zone has been broken up, busted up by the police. The police come in, swinging billy clubs, people spread out. And so that's why you got the tents all by they clubs, people spread out. And so that's why you got the tents all by the freeway, all over here.
别致的咖啡馆。它被称为艺术区（Arts District）。随着斯基德罗周围的地区继续绅士化，蚕食着社区的边缘，斯基德罗本身也发生了变化。包括通用多贡所说的警察的存在。2006年，市政府发起了他们所谓的“更安全城市倡议”（Safer Cities Initiative），这为斯基德罗带来了110名额外的警察。所以那个遏制区已经被警察打破、捣毁了。警察进来，挥舞着警棍，人们四散奔逃。所以这就是为什么你在高速公路旁、到处都有帐篷的原因。
Because people say f*** it. You know what I'm saying? I'd rather be over here on 43rd Street in my tent, you know, than be able to chill out, you know what I'm saying? Than being on St. Julian Street against the wall being jacked up three or four times a day. Back in 1976, when El Cesar and Morris and other activists came up with the containment plan, they included a map that laid out exactly what the borders of Skid Row would be.
因为人们说去他妈的。你知道我的意思吗？我宁愿在第43街的帐篷里，你知道吗，也不愿在圣朱利安街（St. Julian Street）靠着墙，一天被警察搜身三四次。早在1976年，当埃尔塞瑟、莫里斯和其他活动人士提出“遏制计划”时，他们附上了一张地图，精确地标出了斯基德罗的边界。
They were trying to make a deal, a kind of compromise. We'll stay over here. Just don't try to push us out with new development, and we will stay contained. Everybody that signed up for housing is still on the street. That's right. Not here. Put that. Come on. Just a couple weeks ago, Skid Row residents and activists were out on the street fighting for those same borders, the ones from the 1976 containment plan,
他们试图达成一项交易，一种妥协。我们会待在这里。只要别试图通过新的开发项目把我们赶走，我们就会保持被遏制的状态。所有报名申请住房的人仍然在街上。没错。不在这里。把那个写下来。来吧。就在几周前，斯基德罗的居民和活动人士还在街上为同样的边界而战，那些来自1976年“遏制计划”的边界，
but with a different attitude. They're not trying to contain Skid Row. They're trying to contain development, or at least the luxury housing development that's currently being considered right at the edge of Skid Row. It's a 33-story high-rise apartment building, just needs approval from the local councilmen to move forward. There are about two dozen people at the protest, including General Dogon. This is ours. Don't build here, they're saying. Or else...
但态度不同。他们不是在试图遏制斯基德罗。他们是在试图遏制开发，或者至少是目前正在斯基德罗边缘考虑的豪华住宅开发项目。那是一栋33层的高层公寓楼，只需要当地议员的批准就可以推进。抗议活动中有大约两打人，包括通用多贡。这是我们的。别在这里盖楼，他们说。否则……
We'll be back! We'll be back! We'll be back! We'll be back! L.A. Skid Row was not the first Skid Row. Avery Troubleman has a story of what is rumored to be the first use of the phrase after this. So I'm in the studio with Avery Troubleman and coincidentally you were doing a story in Seattle where you ended up on another Skid Row. And not just any Skid Row. It was maybe where the name skid row comes from. So if you go to Seattle and you go downtown, you will encounter a place called Pioneer Square, which is actually a triangle.
我们会回来的！我们会回来的！我们会回来的！我们会回来的！洛杉矶的斯基德罗并不是第一个斯基德罗。艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）在之后有一个关于据传是该短语首次使用的故事。所以我现在和艾弗里·特鲁夫曼在演播室里，巧合的是，你在西雅图做报道时，最终到了另一个斯基德罗。而且不仅仅是任何斯基德罗。它可能是“斯基德罗”（Skid Row）这个名字的来源。所以如果你去西雅图，去市中心，你会遇到一个叫先锋广场（Pioneer Square）的地方，它实际上是一个三角形。
And it is the tourist area. And Seattle used to be a really big logging town. And the mill used to be right downtown. So loggers would go up into the hills and chop down these massive huge trees and they'd lubricate them with fish oil and hook the logs up to teams of oxen and mules. And then would run the logs down this road over to the mill. Now that would be called dragging or skidding the logs. Skidding the logs makes this road the skid road.
它是旅游区。西雅图过去是一个非常大的伐木城镇。磨坊过去就在市中心。所以伐木工会到山上砍伐这些巨大的树木，他们会用鱼油润滑它们，把原木钩在牛和骡子的队伍上。然后会把原木沿着这条路拖到磨坊。现在这被称为拖拽或“滑行”（skidding）原木。滑行原木使这条路成为“滑行路”（Skid Road）。
It was called Skid Road with a D according to my guide Dean Najarian and that street is now called Yesler Way because Henry Yesler was the owner of the mill at the end of the street where the logs were being skidded down to. And this mill was also very close to the seaport. And so here in this part of town you've got these sailors who are taking their shore leave and then these loggers, there are like a lot of guys around and they've got these hard jobs with long periods of downtime. They are looking for action and fun.
根据我的向导迪恩·纳贾里安（Dean Najarian）的说法，它被称为带D的“Skid Road”，那条街现在叫耶斯勒路（Yesler Way），因为亨利·耶斯勒（Henry Yesler）是街道尽头磨坊的主人，原木就是被滑行到那里的。这个磨坊也离海港非常近。所以在这个城镇的这一部分，你有这些正在休岸假的船员，然后是这些伐木工，周围有很多男人，他们有这些艰苦的工作，有很长的停工期。他们在寻找刺激和乐趣。
Luckily, Seattle in this area, in the skid row was here to provide. Before there was Vegas, Sin City was right here. A lot of bars, a lot of brothels. So this is the original Skid Row? Maybe, maybe. There were other towns, I have to confess, there were other towns that had Skid Roads as a functional term of the logging industry in other parts of the world.
幸运的是，西雅图在这个区域，在斯基德罗，提供了这些。在拉斯维加斯出现之前，罪恶之城就在这里。很多酒吧，很多妓院。所以这是最初的斯基德罗？也许吧，也许吧。我必须承认，还有其他城镇，在世界其他地方，有作为伐木业功能术语的“Skid Roads”。
I don't know if those other Skid Roads also developed like bars and red light districts and you know, rough attitudes, but that's definitely what happened in Seattle. Thanks for stepping in. Yeah, thank you. Since this episode aired the debate on rezoning Skid Row has continued on. Advocates are fighting for affordable housing to be part of any proposal but the homeless population is still facing the same lack of legal protections. And now, with the recent SCOTUS ruling, there's a risk that cities in a similar position will
我不知道那些其他的“Skid Roads”是否也发展成了酒吧和红灯区，你知道，粗犷的态度，但这绝对是西雅图发生的事情。谢谢你的加入。是的，谢谢你。自本集播出以来，关于斯基德罗重新分区的辩论仍在继续。倡导者们正在争取将经济适用房作为任何提案的一部分，但无家可归者群体仍然面临着同样的法律保护缺失。现在，随着最高法院最近的裁决，存在一种风险，即处于类似地位的城市将
turn simply to fining, arresting, and jailing the unhoused populations. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Carla Green, mixed by Sharif Youssef, music by Swan Real, additional production and voice acting by Avery Truffleman. Special thanks this week to John Malpete and Henriette Browers from the Los Angeles Poverty Department. Thanks as well to Linus Shintu and everyone at the Los Angeles Community Action Network. If this episode resonated with you, I recommend you go back and listen to our series called According to Need by Katie Mingle.
简单地转向罚款、逮捕和监禁无家可归者。《99%隐形》本周由卡拉·格林制作，谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Youssef）混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，额外的制作和配音由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼完成。本周特别感谢来自洛杉矶贫困部门的约翰·马尔佩特（John Malpete）和亨丽埃特·布劳尔斯（Henriette Browers）。同样感谢莱纳斯·辛图（Linus Shintu）和洛杉矶社区行动网络的所有人。如果这一集引起了你的共鸣，我建议你回去听听我们由凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）制作的名为《根据需求》（According to Need）的系列节目。
It covers the challenges of truly addressing homelessness instead of just trying to sweep people away to somewhere else. It's one of the best things we've ever done. I hope you check it out. Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. Nikita Apte is our intern.
它涵盖了真正解决无家可归问题而不是仅仅试图把人们扫地出门到其他地方的挑战。这是我们做过的最好的事情之一。我希望你去看看。凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。尼基塔·阿普特（Nikita Apte）是我们的实习生。
The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful uptown Oakland, California, home of the Oakland Roots soccer club of which I'm a proud community owner.
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、拉什玛·道恩（Lashma Dawn）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、尼娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们现在是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，这里是奥克兰根足球俱乐部的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。
Other teams may come and go, but the roots are Oakland first, always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
其他球队可能会来来去去，但根基永远是奥克兰第一。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。你可以在99PI.org找到该链接以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。